Salut les mentalos!
Il y a quelques semaines on a eu le plaisir de recevoir sur cette chaîne Bernard Werber
qui nous parlait de son nouveau spectacle
et j'ai eu aussi le plaisir en même temps de me faire offrir son nouveau livre
avant qu'il sorte.
J'ai fini de le lire et j'aimerai bien vous en parler
Pour ça j'ai contacté directement les éditions Albin Michel
pour qu'ils puissent m'envoyer quelques exemplaires
et que je puisse vous les offrir!
Je vous explique tous ça à la fin de la vidéo
pour l'instant je vous présente "Demain, les chats"!
Générique!
Quoi? Oui générique
Le nouveau livre de Bernard Werber est donc sorti hier
J'avais eu la chance de pouvoir commencer à le lire en avance
et je vous le dis direct : c'est une réussite.
J'ai pas tellement envie de vous révéler toute l'intrigue
et de vous priver des surprises que vous aurez en lisant ce livre,
mais je vous dévoile pas grand chose si je vous dit que, par exemple
le point de vue principal est celui d'un chat.
D'un chat fille, donc c'est celui d'une chatte.
L’intérêt de ce point de vue c'est que l'on va découvrir toute la société humaine
selon le regard et le mode de pensée d'un chat.
Dans les premières pages du livre, je me suis dit c'est original, c'est ambitieux
mais du coup ce qui est original et ambitieux est sûrement dur à mettre en place
En l'occurrence ça fonctionne très bien.
Mais au-delà de l'histoire, c'est pas le seul point fort de ce roman.
Pour moi le vrai point fort
c'est que Bernard Werber s'inscrit comme un auteur vraiment contemporain,
au sens littéral du terme.
Le livre se passe réellement aujourd'hui,
l'actualité qu'il y a dans l'histoire nous rappelle la notre en permanence,
les technologies citées dans l'histoire sont vraiment celles que j'utilise moi au quotidien.
J'avais eu cette impression comme ça de réalisme, de quotidien,
quand j'avais lu le livre "Le Papillon des étoiles"
et ça me l'a refait dans "Demain les chats".
Et quand j'ai terminé de le lire je me suis dit: "mais en fait c'est quoi ce roman?"
Je veux dire au-delà même de l'histoire, de l'intrigue, etc, c'est quoi "Demain les chats"?
Je crois que l'on pourrait dire que c'est une science fiction réaliste,
une espèce de SF très moderne.
Je sais pas si c'est très clair ce que je dis mais j'ai eu l'impression de lire
du Jules Verne de 2016, dans une certaine mesure,
avec un traitement du suspens aussi fort et aussi puissant que celui que met Stephen King.
Je pense que c'est plus qu'un autres des romans de Bernard Werber,
une autre sortie de livre
Je pense que ce livre là c'est une espèce de confirmation.
Ce qui donne encore plus envie de voir ce qu'il va écrire dans les prochaines années
et de lire ses futurs publications.
L’héroïne du  livre c'est Bastet,
c'est elle, je suppose en tout cas que c'est elle sur la couverture.
Elle va évoluer, elle va jouer, elle va juger, elle va essayer de comprendre, voire essayer de communiquer
avec tout le monde des humains.
Et on découvrira au travers d'elle le père potentiel de ses enfants,
Son meilleur ami qui s’appelle Pythagore, c'est un siamois.
C'est un siamois geek.
Et il est aussi fascinant que l'était le véritable Pythagore.
Je vous remet un lien vers la vidéo de la discussion que j'avais eu avec Bernard Werber
Où il nous parle de Pythagore et on sent vraiment que le côté fascinant du personnage on le retrouve dans le siamois
Et puis, il y a également la servante de Bastet
La servante que nous, dans notre langage on appelle la maitresse
tout est une question de point de vue.
Je vous recommande de le lire, de l'acheter, de vous le faire prêter, de le prendre dans une bibliothèque, ou dans une médiathèque
si vous en avez l'occasion.
que vous ayez déjà lu des livres ou pas de cet auteur là.
Peu importe
C'est une histoire isolée des autres histoires
donc vous pouvez la commencer et vous allez être tout de suite kidnappé et vous allez tourner les pages comme ça.
tout le temps
Avant d'aller plus loin je tiens à préciser que ceci n'est pas un placement de produit
je n'ai pas reçu d'argent pour ça. Je n'ai pas été contacté pour ça
Je comptais faire une vidéo dessus, par rapport à ce que j'avais déjà fait sur les livres de Bernard Werber au début d'année,
puis la conversation qu'on a eu l'autre jour
et j'ai eu un contact direct avec Albin Michel
pour recevoir des livres, pour vous
parce que là je me suis dit, quitte à faire une vidéo dessus si je peux leur faire gagner des livres, c'est cool.
Alors, ils m'ont envoyé un coursier
et ce coursier m'a amené, non pas 1 livre parce qu'à la base  c'était pour un livre
mais 5 exemplaires
1, 2, 3, 4, 5 exemplaires pour vous,
tous dédicacés par l'auteur et ça c'est collector mon pote
Pour vous les faire gagner, je fais un tirage au sort.
La dernière fois, j'ai vraiment galérer la semaine dernière pour le tirage au sort vous m'avez envoyé quasiment 3000 mails
donc je me suis dit, je vais le faire sur les réseaux sociaux mais tout le monde n'est pas connecté à tout les réseaux sociaux
donc c'était encore une galère
J'ai trouvé la solution ultime, je vais faire un Google Form
Je vous met le lien dans la descritpion
Vous rentrez votre nom, votre prénom, votre mail
Tirage au sort, dimanche on va dire dimanche ça vous laisse la semaine pour participer
Et dimanche je ferais une vidéo bonus en plus de la vidéo du dimanche
où je filmerais directement le tirage au sort avec tout les mails
Est ce que c'était bien clair ce que j'ai dit.
C'est pas sûr
Il y a un lien directement dans la description, pour participer au tirage au sort que je ferais le 9 octobre
Vous avez aussi peut être remarqué que j'ai commencé à modifier des choses sur la chaine
j'en avais parlé fin août, ça arrive tout doucement
J'ai mis quand même de chose aujourd'hui
les plus attentifs, d'entre vous, avez vu des images subliminales traîner dans les vidéos
que j'avais fait ces 7 derniers jours
Voilà, là il y a quasiment tout, il manque encore les nouvelles musiques et 2-3 petites choses
mais je suis très content de tout ça
Et le logo, c'est à force de lire vos commentaires que j'ai fait ce logo là.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, je vous prépare quelques choses de très, très surprenant
pour demain 17h
Quelques choses que j'ai jamais fait sur la chaîne, que j'ai jamais fait tout court d'ailleurs
alors je sais pas si ça va être du génie ou si ça va être ridicule
Mais en tout cas ça va être fait quoiqu'il arrive
et ce sera inédit sur cette chaîne.
N'oubliez pas de soutenir la vidéo d'un
pouce en l'air.
Si la vidéo vous a plu évidemment. Vous pouvez également
vous abonner avant de partir, si c'est pas déjà fait.
Et rendez vous demain à 17h.
Tchao !